Stanford University we are in a new era
of electrical engineering it is based on
the new type of fabrication technologies
so that we didn't have available to us
just a few years ago
hello I'm Huell of Silla guard I'm here
to tell you about our brand new program
in nanotechnology you've heard about the
Internet of Things that's what we're
working on right now so this is a
toolbox essentially I'm going to give
you a new toolbox from making things
that are really going to be important
going forward
it is based on 19 fabrication
technologies that are cleanroom base
that are based on optical lithography
but not only that there's also sort of
adding another dimension to it something
that wasn't there before I think it
really spans the gamut of industry it
also spans the gamut of people within
those industry if you are a young person
they're still sort of designing things
if you're a middle manager if you are at
already at the top level now you go to
direct your company and you need to
understand what opportunities are there
so this is really wide ranging and
covering a large number of industries
and also roles within those industries
so if you are interested in learning how
to make new stuff more personalized
Serkis be part of the personalized
health revolution this is the type of
thing that you want to learn more about
you need to know about the opportunities
that nanotechnology affords you in terms
of building new systems
you